hey guys how's it going so it's been a
few days with the new iPhone 6s and one
of the biggest questions that I got was
Justine did you start fresh on your new
iPhone or did you do a restore from
iCloud I actually started fresh and I do
this pretty much every single time that
I get a phone it's good in a way because
it feels really great to just start
fresh with a completely new phone no
photos no messages no nothing but the
problem is a lot of my game data
especially oh gosh it upsets me because
I do lose a lot of that stuff in the
long run I feel pretty good about my
decisions the good thing about some of
the games you can make sure that they're
connected to Facebook or they're
connected to the server and you can
usually save most of your data that way
some games save locally so it doesn't
work that way some of you guys wanted to
know what I have on my current iPhone
success I will do what was on my iPhone
6 this case is an instance in CPU CPU I
got at Walmart and it's clear the
problem with clear cases though is
usually in the past stuff kind of gets
in between and it's really annoying so
far so good on this one but I've only
had it a couple of days so let's go
through real quick and see what the apps
that I have in my phone my sister said
well I don't want to start over because
I won't be able to remember what apps I
had I'm like if you don't remember what
apps you had those apps clearly weren't
important so right now I've got
everything sort of organized by what
I've been using most I've got my
calendar I've got my clock my maps my
Apple maps my Google Maps the App Store
ok I've got my notes setting swarm vine
layout which is instagrams layout app
iOS snapchat I got my Twitter - Twitter
so I got my tweet bought and Twitter
Facebook and Facebook mentions Spotify
Apple music tumblr my phone Instagram
trip picks NFL fantasy and then on the
other page I've got all of my Canon
camera apps a GoPro app my YouTube apps
and in here's all the Apple stuff that I
don't really
care about that much they don't really
ever use got my messenger my NFL mobile
and my sky whale game which is so much
fun but I lost all my data so it doesn't
have my high score save I also want to
show you guys this app it's called trip
pics but this app will let you choose a
bunch of photos from either a trip or an
adventure
I was picking one and coming through and
making a little look of Maddie's little
vacation adventures I'll see I already
started it I really write it and finish
and you go through you pick the photos
this was a grand adventure clearly yeah
add a map here Bree was actually pretty
rainy boat-car plane fell here's my
little book I created Maddie's big
adventure I want to make one of some of
his baby pictures so you click ordered
it links you up the Shutterfly and
that's basically it it will come to your
house so those are some of the apps that
I've been using I asked you guys on
Twitter the other day though for some
new iPhone games because I kind of want
to do some iPhone games on my gaming
channel I feel really bad that I haven't
been posting many videos on the gaming
channel I've been traveling a lot and
most of the time that I've been playing
video games when I was at home I didn't
record any of it it was actually just
playing so it's very hard sometimes to
travel want to play video games for fun
and then have to record and edit all of
that because I sometimes I don't want to
talk to the camera while playing video
games I hope you guys are doing awesome
I hope that you guys are all enjoying
your new iPhones if you've got them and
if you didn't get them it's okay because
really there isn't that huge of an
upgrade from the sixth of success one of
the biggest differences though that I
have noticed is how quick the touch ID
is I mean it I don't I don't even have
to do anything like I just push the
button like I touch it it's like oh okay
you want to login great touch fast I'll
see you guys later in the next video I
will do one of what was on my iPhone 6
because I was gonna do that in this
video but there's so many apps that I
feel I feel great now that my phone is
super clean and fresh and new see you
later